if you want to if you want a digital
currency you have to deal something
different I don't think that the stable
coins are good uh uh because then you're
getting a fiat currency again I think
that what you really would what would be
best is an inflation linked
um coin right in other words something
where basically you would say okay this
is going to give me mind power because
every individual wants what do they want
they want to secure their buying power
if you want to save now if you put it in
Bitcoin it goes like this who knows what
happens if you put it into something the
closest thing to that is an inflation
index Bond and so on but if you put if
you created a coin that says okay this
is buying power then I know I could save
in and put my money and over a period of
time and then I can transact in anywhere
I think that that would be a good coin
but you so I think you're going to see
probably the development of coins that
you haven't seen that probably will be
in end up being attractive viable coins
I don't think Bitcoin is it